2022 was a breakthrough year for
generative AI the form of artificial
intelligence that uses human prompts to
generate unique text and images from
Dolly to lensa people are using image
generators mostly to screw around on the
internet but we're entering the age of
sophisticated text AI which will
revolutionize everything from customer
service to poetry chat GPT requires a
prompt to generate large volumes of
Fairly sophisticated texts answering
follow-up questions admitting its
mistakes challenging incorrect premises
and rejecting inappropriate requests
described as a second brain chat GPT
will free up some people to work
different jobs as technology always does
but it'll allow other people to do the
same work more productively chat GPT
could write the first draft of a
professor's syllabus suggest story lines
for a TV show craft portions of a
journalist's article or create website
copied language AI will change how we do
our jobs in much the same way search did